Gulliver crack bonjour vous êtes à Kiev
pour France 24 volo dix meilleurs
Zelenski il a prévenu à l'hiver sera
sans doute rude
oui on se demande d'ici à keV si on va
vivre en hiver similaire à l'hiver
dernier ou des frappes russes sur les
infrastructures de génération et
distribution d'électricité avait
provoqué des coupures de courant très
fréquents systématique même mais la
situation maintenant est un peu
différente parce que l'Ukraine dispose
de beaucoup plus de système de défense
anti-aérien tous les requêtes qui
visaient la capitale au petit matin
aujourd'hui ont été abattus par les
missiles solaires sans faire de dégâts
majeur ce n'est pas toujours le cas mais
c'est le cas la plupart des temps il y a
rarement maintenant des dégâts majeurs
toutefois le système énergétique est
déjà endommagé les Ukrainiens n'ont pas
pu tout réparer alors c'est quelque
chose qui inquiète pour cet hiver et
l'une des domaines où les États-Unis ont
promis d'aider
blinken Anthony blinken était donc là
aujourd'hui vous avez dit il a promis
d'aider on évoque une aide d'un milliard
de dollars c'est effectivement le cadeau
d'Anthony blinken aux Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui
un milliard qui se rajoute à plus de 70
milliards de dollars au total d'aide
American à l'Ukraine dont 43 milliards
de dollars on a été militaire surtout
Anthony blinken est venu c'est ces mots
rassurer les Ukrainiens que le soutien
des États-Unis va continuer il a été
juste on a vu sa conférence de presse
avec ce homologue ukrainien de mitro a
coulé bas où il disait que l'Ukraine
allait et devait gagner cette guerre ça
c'est Anthony blinken mitro coulibal lui
a profité de l'opportunité pour rappeler
son audience et son homologue que ce
n'est pas uniquement une guerre pour
protéger l'Ukraine mais bien pour
protéger les valeurs de l'Ouest en
général la démocratie etc contre
l'autoritarisme et les mots de métro les
bas pour souligner cela c'était de dire
si le l'Occident ne peut pas gagner
cette guerre alors quelle guerre est-ce
que l'Occident
de gagner il en va de la confiance en
les États-Unis et les autres pouvoirs
occidentaux démocratiques que de
continuer de soutenir l'Ukraine ça c'est
l'argument qui va être présenté par
l'Ukraine et ses partisans contre
Anthony comme Anthony blinken contre des
voies alternatives qui s'élèvent de plus
en plus y compris aux États-Unis ou
certains candidats républicains
maintenant argumentent pour cesser
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine merci
Gulliver Craig avec nous en direct